[Musique]
amb incroyable surtout surtout quand il
marque le premier but là W mes oreilles
cétait quelque
[Applaudissements]
chose très très ému de cette canne c'est
très très bonneg
P vent ça va le pays rend très ha le
pays vraiment je suis en joie d'être
ivoirien être ivoirien c'est une
bénédiction ons hommage à nos autorités
vraiment ce qui vient d'être fait du
Grand con quand c à Paris dès que tu r
les Parisiens qui r écr mais ça c'est
quel ça ça on peut dire avec si stades
c'est la meilleure CAN avec beaucoup
d'infrastructure avec le beau stade
Alassan Ouatara non c'est la meilleure
can je suis sûr on a un slogan en côte
d'ivoireand qui ser quand
sais quand on voit là quand on voit
terrain jolie personne joli Mousseau on
sait que quand qui sera d'ù là on connaî
alors vive le pays du payant vive le
pays du payant vive la
cte